♪ ♪
>> Tammy: BIDEN'S FAILURES ARE
GOING FROM BAD TO WORSE.
AS A NEW POLL FROM GALLUP FINDS
THAT A WHOPPING 83% OF AMERICANS
ARE DISSATISFIED WITH THE
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY, ALL
WHILE BIDENS APPROVAL REMAINS AT
A DISMAL 41% WITH SOME OTHER
POLLS HAVING IT AS LOW AS MID
30s.
THIS COMES AS THE DESTRUCTIVE
DEMOCRAT AGENDA IS FAILING ON
EVERY SINGLE FRONT WE SEE
EVERYDAY IN IN OUR LIVES
INFLATION IS HOVERING AT A 40
YEAR HIGH.
GAS PRICES CONTINUE TO HIT ONE
RECORD HIGH AFTER ANOTHER.
RECORD NUMBERS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE WALTZING ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
BIDENS WE DIPLOMACY ARE AROUSING
DICTATORS ACROSS THE GLOBE, ALL
WELL CRIME SURGES IN
GUN VIOLENCE ARE PLAGUING THE
STREETS.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT'S SOLUTION
TO ALL THESE GROWING CRISES?
TO FURTHER DIVIDE THE COUNTRY,
AND TO SURRENDER HIS -- TO
SURRENDER HIS AGENDA TO THE FAR
FRINGE LEFT.
IT'S NEVER REALLY BEEN -- WHAT
AGENDA DID HE HAVE, EXCEPT TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
THESE ARE THE EXTREMISTS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FOR EXAMPLE, YESTERDAY BIDENS
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
IN THE MIDST OF ALL THIS APPEARS
TO BE JUST ANOTHER EFFORT TO
DEMONIZE THE COPS.
ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
TOLD FOX NEWS IT WAS A
"POLITICAL RESPONSE" TO ACTIVIST
DEMANDS.
WELL, WHAT'S NEW?
NOW THE ORDER INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE IMPLEMENTING A NEW -- "NEW
EVIDENCE INFORMED ANNUAL
ANTIBIAS TRAINING REQUIREMENT
POSTCODE.
AND "REIMAGINES CRISIS RESPONSE
SCHOOL.
WE'VE HEARD THAT BEFORE.
IT'S NOT GOOD.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
BUT JUST LIKE CLOCKWORK, THE
RESIDENT GRIFTERS OVER AT BLACK
LIVES MATTER USED THE OCCASION
TO LAUNCH MORE SMEARS AGAINST
THE POLICE WITH THE GROUP
TWEETING "MAINTAINING A WHITE
SUPREMACIST INSTITUTION LIKE
POLICING COSTS BLACK LIVES.
THIS CONTINUED COMMITMENT BY
POLITICIANS TO SUPPORT OUR
KILLERS MAKES THEM ACCESSORIES."
UNLESS YOU'RE LIVING IN A
$6 MILLION MANSION LIKE THEY
ARE.
HERE FOR REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LEO TERRELL ALONG
WITH AMERICA FIRST LEGAL FOUNDER
STEPHEN MILLER.
LEO, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WE ARE INVOLVED IN THESE ISSUES
ON THE FRONT LINES.
WE ARE REGULAR AMERICANS, WE
HAVE GREAT JOBS.
I LOVE THE JOB I DO.
YOU'VE BEEN AN ACTIVIST AND A
COMMUNITY PERSON ALL OF YOUR
ADULT LIFE, BOTH OF US ON THE
WRONG SIDE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME,
BUT THIS REALLY -- I'D LIKE YOU
TO ADDRESS THIS SEEMINGLY
CANCEROUS NATURE OF HOW NONE OF
THIS STOPS AND HOW IT SEEMS TO
BE BORING INTO WANTING MORE
DISASTER AFTER MORE DISASTER
AFTER MORE DISASTER.
>> THANK YOU, TAMMY, FOR HAVING
ME.
I'M GLAD TO BE ON WITH STEPHEN
AS WELL.
JOE BIDEN IS AN EMPTY SUIT.
YOU SAID IT, HE'S TAKING HIS
MARCHING ORDERS FROM THE EXTREME
LEFT.
HE'S DOING ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
HELP THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
CITIZEN BECAUSE THE EXTREME LEFT
HAS ALREADY DOUBLED DOWN ON THIS
DISASTERS ECONOMIC POLICY.
IT'S JUST HORRIFIC.
WHAT HE DID AGAINST HIM -- THE
GEORGE FLOYD ACT, EXECUTIVE
ORDER, TOOTHLESS, TAMMY.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ADDRESS STATE
AND LOCAL OFFICER -- OVER THESE
FEDERAL OFFICERS AND THE SAD
PART ABOUT IT IS THAT
DONALD TRUMP AND TIM SCOTT TRIED
TO GET POLICE REFORM
LEGISLATION -- STEVE WILL TELL
YOU THAT.
AND GUESS WHO BLOCKED IT?
CORY BOOKER, KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
ALLOW PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
TIM SCOTT TO SHOW THAT THEY
BELIEVE THAT POLICE REFORM WAS
NECESSARY.
SO YOU GET A TOOTHLESS EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
IT'S MEANINGLESS AND I WILL TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW, JOE BIDEN IN NAME
ONLY AS PRESIDENT, BUT THE
EXTREME LEFT IS RUNNING THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Tammy: AND WE SEE THE
RESULTS, STEPHEN, WITH ALL THOSE
DISASTERS.
WE ALL KNOW AS THEY ARE PLAYING
OUT, THEY'RE NOT EVEN STAYING
STATIC.
THEY ARE GETTING WORSE OVER
TIME, AND WE ALL KNOW, WE ARE
NOT SURPRISED, AND SO THERE IS
SOMETHING AFOOT.
THERE'S NO EFFORT TO EVEN JUST
LIKE LET'S JUST KEEP IT AT A 20
YEAR HIGH.
IT GOES TO A 40 YEAR HIGH.
IS THIS JUST INCOMPETENCE, OR DO
YOU SEE THIS AS PART PERHAPS OF
AN AGENDA THAT IS BEING
DELIBERATELY IMPLEMENTED THIS
POINT?
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
EFFECTIVELY RUN BY MARXIST
REVOLUTIONARIES.
THERE'S NO POLL THAT'S GOING TO
STOP THEM.
BEING VOTED OUT OF POWER IS THE
ONLY THING -- THE ONLY THING
THAT'S GOING TO STOP THEM.
EVERY DAY THEY SHOW UP TO WORK
ASKING THEMSELVES HOW CAN I
ADVANCE ANOTHER RADICAL MARXIST
DIRECTIVE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT -- HERE IS
SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE NOT
DISCUSSING IN THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
IT RESTRICTS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM PROVIDING
SURPLUS MILITARY EQUIPMENT TO
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT.
SOMETHING PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ON
THE EXACT OPPOSITE SIDE OF,
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE THAT
EQUIPMENT.
WHY DOES IT MATTER?
IF SOMEBODY COMES TO YOUR SCHOOL
AND STARTS SHOOTING, YOU WANT
POLICE OFFICERS TO GET THERE ON
THE SCENE IN 60 SECONDS WITH THE
BEST ARMOR, THE BEST EQUIPMENT,
THE MOST POWERFUL WEAPONRY THEY
HAVE, TO OBLITERATE, TO
OBLITERATE THAT SCHOOL SHOOTER.
WHY IN GOD'S NAME -- WHY IN
GOD'S NAME NOW OF ALL TIMES DO
WE TAKE AWAY THIS EQUIPMENT FROM
OUR POLICE OFFICERS?
IT'S JUST ONE RADICAL DIRECTIVE
AFTER ANOTHER WITH NO THOUGHT
FOR WHAT IT DOES TO THE LIVES OF
EVERYDAY CITIZENS.
>> Tammy: AND IT WOULD SAY
ALSO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DISTURBED YOUNG MAN WAS REALLY
MAD AT ALL YOU HEAR IS TALK
ABOUT DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS EVIL, YOU
KNOW THEY ARE UNDERFUNDED, YOU
KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED, THAT PROBABLY MAKES IT A
TINY BIT EASIER TO TAKE A CHANCE
THAT YOU NORMALLY WOULDN'T TAKE
IF THE POLICE ARE GOING TO COME
DOWN ON YOU LIKE A HAMMER.
>> WITHOUT COPS WE ARE ALL LESS
SAFE AND THOUSANDS MORE WILL
NEEDLESSLY BE KILLED IN STREET
CRIME BECAUSE THE POLICE ARE
BEING TOLD TO PULL BACK AND NOT
DO THEIR JOBS.
>> Tammy: LEO, DO YOU THINK
THIS IS A FACTOR -- YOU KNOW,
IT'S MORE OF A KIND OF
UNDERCURRENT FACTOR WHEN
CRIMINALS AND OTHERS -- YOU
KNOW, WE HAD A HORRIBLE SHOOTING
ON THE SUBWAY HERE IN NEW YORK,
CRIME IN LOS ANGELES CONTINUES
COMEDIES HOME INVASION
ROBBERIES, THE SCHOOL SHOOTING,
THE SLAUGHTER OF CHILDREN, IS
THIS -- DO YOU THINK THIS IS
PART OF THIS CULTURAL RHETORIC
THAT THE LEFT HAS MOVED THAT
ENCOURAGES AND INSPIRES THE
DISTURBED?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET ME TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, THE
CRIMINALS ARE ELATED WITH
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THESE
CITIES.
EVERYDAY WE TALK ABOUT THE
CRIME, AND I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW, THE REASON IS VERY SIMPLE.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY EVERYTHING
GOOD ABOUT THIS COUNTRY.
STEPHEN SAID IT BEST COMEDIES
ARE MARXISTS WHO WANT TO DESTROY
EVERY INSTITUTION, THEY WANT TO
DESTROY THE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
BLACK LIVES MATTER -- LET ME BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT THEM.
THEY GOT NO COURT ABILITY.
I HOPE EVERY AG IN THE STATE
INVESTIGATES THEM.
WHEN THERE IS THAT TSUNAMI
LANDSLIDE VICTORY BY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, PLEASE
INVESTIGATE BLM.
THEY HAVE NO COURT ABILITY, THEY
DON'T SPEAK FOR ANY PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY OTHER THAN THEIR
MANSIONS.
>> Tammy: LET ME TELL YOU --
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU.
ALL OF THIS KIND OF RHETORIC,
THE PEOPLE DOING THE WORST
THINGS, OR HOPING THEY'RE GOING
TO RAISE MONEY.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT IS SEXIEST.
HOW THEY CAN MANIPULATE AND USE
AND ALL OF THEM CAME TO THE
FRONT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE LEFT OUT OF THE MONEY THAT
CAN BE RAISED.
THIS IS NOT AN AMERICAN --
AMERICANS HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
MOMS HAVE H